If you have gone through the trouble of hiring an attorney
for a custody case, you have this little plot note is what you need.
This thing is an AI voice recorder.
Chat GPT empowered. And it takes notes for you
so it can record phone calls.
So when your attorney calls
and you need to remember all the important details
they're telling you, the plot has got you.
If you're in an actual meeting,
like in person, maybe even in court,
and you just wanna remember what's happening,
you have a tool to help you.
What you simply do is you push this little button,
the light turns on and that lets you know that it's recording.
It's connected via Bluetooth to your phone.
It will transcribe everything that's happening.
And then you get to pick through the app
if you want a mind map, if you want a transcript,
if you want a summary,
you can download that to your phone in a PDF form
and you have all that information sorted for you.
So you don't have to remember anymore,
you don't have to take notes,
and you don't have to feel flustered
and pressured to remember everything.
This little guy is on the TikTok shop
and is absolutely worth every single penny.
It's linked right here. Go grab one.